how's it going there reject nation john
coy we are here today to watch hawkeye
episode five we know elena's back
suspiciously
kingpin
and uh
yeah man i've been hearing that this
episode is going to be a big one there's
some people at the higher ups who've
been teasing this one so guys make sure
to go ahead hit that like button if you
haven't enjoyed this video subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction to the finale
is up of course full length watch along
as we sync up with the time code over at
our patreon page cover a bunch of shows
over there as well lastly thanks to the
boys over at prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights koi
this is not healthy all right guys it is
healthy
yes
still waiting on my rogers the musical
guys did you order a shirt hell's yeah
this is why i don't go off topic it just
leads down the trade
[Music]
elena origins
in the hawkeye show elena identity yeah
the show has more origins than most
[Music]
potentially missed
do it
i'm trying to help you then why'd you
break into my house what not yet hold
her hand get her with the episode
okay
yeah
it's directly continuing
right out of it waking him up
look what you did to my rug
20 000 down the drain thanks excuse me
i don't think she was brainwashed what
you thought i was some rich perverts
prisoner
elena how is your sister doing
because she's doing okay good yeah she's
good and then you and natasha will be
reunited and go live your sex
mississippi fantasy in new york
those peloton stocks
this show's way more connected to the
other movies than
i think we've seen so far very true
oh
wow
oh
oh
that's perspective of someone that oh
that's so cool
[Music]
oh neat that's how she'd experience it
oh that's amazing what's going on
who are you who are you
[Music]
elena oh my god you're
back
[Music]
oh damn is that moon girl
that's a moon girl haircut it's just a
blip in the thing
i need to find natasha
hey can you help me find natasha
i need to tell her i'm okay
let's have fun
wow let's have fun
and you'll be glad to know he then told
me to come home and stay away from him
come here
my baby girl
that's
[Laughter]
clint and i
have been looking into our mom's murder
we found a lot of incriminating stuff
about jack mom
oh god um
he has called sloan limited
stop maybe there's a reason
for all of it i don't know but you just
have to please just promise me that
you'll look into it that's all i ask
okay okay i will
what a really calm response she what a
not affected face
moment
madam mask
kid bishop
[Laughter]
i don't have any weapons on me okay i
take that back i don't have any weapons
currently in my hands
[Laughter]
not that my hands aren't weapons in all
honesty if i wanted to kill you you
would have already right as you open the
door yeah
okay
yeah
they act well right now
i know yeah it's true it worked it was
good
are you done
yeah i go
turkey i can put hot sauce on it
i love american christmases the tree
the presents the super-powered reindeer
rudolph
these
superpowers right deer
[Laughter]
are you in new york to talk to clint is
that why you're here no no no no no no
i'm here to kill him
this is like a territo seed
milk scene
do you know how many people he killed
the trail of blood that follows him you
could wrap around the entire world okay
wow that was
very russian
we are defined by what we do
not by nice words
what's the story she heard about natasha
with elena yeah from yeah what is the
story oh right
do not get in my way again
[Music]
love that scene yeah really like seeing
elena from kate's perspective all guys
are staying in a hotel for christmas
then take my couch
really take my bed i love grills
almost forgot
missy dropped off the new outfits for
you and kate you wanna see him oh
just not writing right now
yeah man you need to rest
i promise you this is all a big
misunderstanding i've never worked a day
in my life
[Laughter]
i looked into it
and you were right don't blame me for
calling the police darling i would have
done exactly the same thing i've
obviously been framed she framed him
she
cool
i love the world building that the
long-form shows allow yep
natasha
you were the bravest of us all weren't
you
loyal
stubborn
you always had to win didn't you but i
do my best every day to learn what you
gave me
someone say i miss you
and i'm so sorry
for what i'm about to do
damn his whole performance in this
little series just made perfect sense to
me
it all came full
package in that one scene natasha is
like the best off-screen character
she supports so much
around her
so the police arrested jack
which is all pretty crazy would be great
to discuss
yeah okay sure i've screwed up a few
times okay fine
whatever i'm still learning
[Laughter]
clint you think i want to leave all
these messages like a crazy person no
this is your fault
kate bishop perfect
yeah a thousand percent
pocket in middle of fight wait one
second please let me put on brass
knuckles so i can punch your feet
[Music]
[Laughter]
delivery arrow
maya meet me tonight where he first met
the roman
alone
but we are not maya
but we're not
if i don't end this tonight
it's just a matter of time before the
big guy gets involved
no
keep teasing the big guy
sinking feeling
then follow your gut
gut
[Laughter]
oh fat man autumn sails
this is the most costly thing we've seen
so far
okay
let's talk
[Music]
it's a jurassic park
here batman begins yeah
[Music]
the hell
[Music]
whoa that's a cool shot
[Music]
[Applause]
damn those kicks yeah
[Music]
i would love it if it's actually grills
under there
[Music]
yes
your boss wanted your father dead
now he's using
[Music]
oh no
i'm gonna go kate yeah this rescue
mission you got an escape plan
hey are you tabitha yes
all right hop on in
this guy gotta run you better get a tip
then rescue avengers uber
that's it
he got away
learn nothing else
end of information
[Music]
i don't know
i
i didn't get the call
no
all these years you never had this
prepared
come on man
you're craftier than this in the comics
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i should have
thought of a lie
you had dozens of years in this this
really is all my fault
look at this
who's that with my mom
[Music]
well that's the guy i've been worried
about this whole time
oh
there it is official confirmation now i
need turk in episode six it's all
happening there's a lot happening this
week and that was vincent's not
forgetting that photo so julia louis
val she
is she like a middle ground between
kingpin went through her to hire elena
okay is yeah is kingpin of some like
dark avengers
i don't think that's what's going on
somebody's doing it i think val is doing
it but i think she kind of used them as
like
mercenaries in a way hmm
oh my god i use the word mercenaries i
never pull out a word like that
real character
do you think it'll say and vincent and
opera oh
even though it's just a photo
ah cowards they don't want that in the
credits they want an imdb
he's back baby nice that's his back
that's so cool now here's where we wait
yeah here's where we wait for them to
not show us the post credits but we will
do we're gonna wait
just for the patrons um
i don't know something the youtube cut
oh yeah was waiting silence might as
well all right well now we know get that
riveting
look at these credits
clearly you guys don't watch the videos
back
[Laughter]
making sure these certain moments are in
here they're human
georgia great state because you know
what other audience members way too damn
you
damn
mine just includes a car
just a car
car door
oh
violence
it's prop comedy my impression
mine's a sugar in water because i go
meta knight and a district
we don't want this we don't want this in
the internet well we were right we're
the only ones on the internet who
guested
wow kudos to us make sure you give us
the right credit as the only ones who
guessed that it was going to be kingpin
spoilers greg i'm sorry guys kingpin
i can't believe how good we all are
because you read the comics you knew too
much yeah exactly
greg
stop reading comics it really is
detrimental to the entire experience of
knowledge i was a little bit surprised
though by the plot twists about um
yeah
the whole thing with how someone was
hired so someone tipped off clint when
he was ronin yeah
to kill maya did to kill people the
tracksuit mafia and kill maya's dad and
i do think it's probably something to do
with like that this will make her the
ultimate weapon because it seems like
from that flashback with maya in that
earlier episode
you know the way he looks after her is
like yeah you will be
my like own black widow
my assassin in a lot of ways so i it
seems like the one thing that kept her
in the the loving state was her dad so
you move that and then it becomes
something just full of rage that blinds
her and that is something like kingpin
does with uh like typhoid mary he does
it with at times he manipulates elektra
against daredevil like that's a very
kingpin move to manipulate in those ways
so i really think it's a great way to
bring him into the mcu and i mean we
only got the one still but that is so
many ramifications of how much is this
gonna tie to the netflix shows is that
stuff canon like how how's all this
going to blend in i'm fascinated i feel
like it has to be canon because like how
do you think that would be too much
that would be a
lot to wrap your head around it
especially when you're yeah you would
because you would have to make it a very
clear distinction somehow and if this
show is not going to do multiverse yeah
just do its own thing
they would have to really uh they would
have to do a multiverse thing in order
to clarify that it's not the same king i
would love if we could daredevil season
four and we get bullseye and the things
that we wanted to see concluded yeah i
would love that peachy
you know what you're doing
excited no matter what it's going to be
i might as well enjoy it i mean
i'll never say that
but at the same time i am like i don't
know how that's going to quite translate
yeah because i feel like part of the
chart i mean you know good storytelling
is good storytelling good characters are
good characters but part of the charm of
those shows is the grit once upon a
deadpool did not work as well as
deadpool yeah it needs to be uh
it needs to be it needs to be violent
but it's still cool to have her back and
i feel like eleanor
um is definitely
inspired by madame mask
but
is not meh i don't think she's gonna
come out wearing a mask and be like i'm
at a mess because it's funny if there's
a scene with rachel weiss in black widow
where there's a mask in her closet that
is madame shape and now elena's in this
and i was like mad at mask is black
widow and then she wasn't and now
there's another thing i'm like madam
mask is and that's probably not yeah
we'll get madame mask one day maybe that
means still it's gonna be cool getting
the mask
somebody stopped me as they say
one day one day
this was another really good episode i i
just love the seam work that they have
here you know they have that opening bit
with uh you know continuation of elena's
journey post black widow trying to save
other black widows watching her blip
moment that was so cool i loved seeing
from the perspective of the blippi yeah
the experience of they would just feel
the transition back into from ash and
then the world would be different for
them so that visualization of that would
be fascinating and her saying i've lost
five years
i don't know how that would feel like
would you feel like you've aged would it
feel like the world has aged like you
you'd have lost five years of other
people's lives but conceptually not your
own on the time meter of your own
existence like all of that is so
fascinating oh yeah it's like going
under surgery yeah yeah it's like oh all
of a sudden i'm fading out and hey i'm
back
there's still like an unaccounted for a
gap and yeah i love the way that they
tempered her character throughout this
episode because she gets so much of it
to kind of walk around in and breathe in
and yeah florence pew is
just a magic to watch her her accent is
even stronger this time around yeah i'm
a huge florence pew fan i'm really so
charming i'm a russian accent expert you
know i'll just say that like when i'm
around when i when i'm around her when i
watch her i
i'm not seeing florence pew i really am
seeing the character elena for sure and
i'm well acquainted with her work enough
to be aware when i'm watching an actor
and i really feel like i'm just watching
elena and that scene in particular as
much as it's exciting that we're going
to finally be getting kingpin back
and uh you know like the plot to us and
stuff my favorite scene is the the one
of the first scenes in here with elena
and kate you know playing this game of
verbal chess with one another and we're
they're both adding on doubt
to each other and i love that it's
captured from primarily like kind of
switching perspectives throughout but
you really see elena more in this
threatening assassin position i like how
you see her in that role when it's not
just her kicking ass and taking names
you're actually watching her have fun
with the interrogation and i thought the
way that whole scene just progressed i
know i said it during it like there's a
tarantino quality about it like when
they're talking just about real life
stuff before you get to the actual why
are we here you know the milk scene in a
glorious bastard yes with macaroni it
made me want macaroni i could actually
like i was so in the moment of it
feeling real that i was like i would in
fact like some boxed cheese but even the
way they would do some of those
close-ups on them really did feel
tarantino inspired in a lot of ways and
tarantino's work has inspired from
directors like brian de palma so
a little bit of michael mann's heat as
well i enjoyed the little slight digital
fragmenting in some of the fights
oh yeah very true yeah good call cinema
reference we watch movies we watch
things
we just can't talk about them
that's real
that's the true thing
depends on how big it is yeah you want
every four videos you spiderman let us
watch
we love spiderman we also love huge
brian de palma movie giants
he's still been killing it
this star is not made it's so
the new world and all of michael mann's
most recent not not a lot of people oh
it's my
reaction let's do it
miami vice collin farrell's mustache
game miami vice is impeccable he's got
room for like two mustaches the new
world's terrance malik it is terence
malik i failed the city but i know if we
further proved our points yeah
let's get back on track now let's get
back to track through colin farrell who
was bullseye in daredevil and is now
penguin so we're gonna watch batman
there you go
plenty to go around here how about maya
um no they weren't sure we could talk
about maya yeah all right talk about
maya john hey no i mean that finally we
got the confrontation between her and
ronan and i mean
you know it's it's i'm curious to know
what you guys think about that because
it is like such a culmination for that
character for her characters her entire
motivation they have that whole
conversation about once we get him we're
done but then also that moment becomes
an alley-oop into a greater much more
grim circumstance surrounding kingpin
and all that so i mean how did the
impact feel to you guys
uh
well
i don't know i i wasn't really too imp i
was more caught up in the re revelation
of the information than i was the
emotional
impact of the scene that was a good
scene i was i wasn't like
this could be better like switch with
hawkeye enough that we felt like he was
gonna like be violent and then it was
the reveal to me was his being like hey
now we're connecting as people like that
was and i like the setup with linda
carlini and like wondering if that was
gonna be a thing and all those moments
worked for me but i also feel like
without renner's skill at being so
nuanced none of that would have worked
like this this show doesn't work without
renner being able to do so much with his
eyeballs well this the theme of this
episode is all about the paths we choose
to take and that's specifically what all
this this particular one is about
and yeah like you're talking about sort
of a mislead he's like calling his wife
like let's kill some [ __ ]
let's go this black little girl
i'm gonna kill this with this there's
def chick i'm going to kill them all man
no ronin's back maybe
all right honey be home for supper like
what a drastic meatloaf
drastically different performance here
we're getting he is ruthless this time
around uh no yeah so it's because he dot
he donned the ronin costume but i felt
like
i don't know the decision that he made
in that moment i love the themes of the
conversation but my first thought was
she's not gonna stop hunting for you
what do you think this is gonna happen
like what did you think this was
suddenly it was a really also the moment
with qazi where qazi is like okay we're
gonna talk about you stopping and then
as soon as you say you're not gonna stop
i'm gonna agree with you again negative
entire conversation there was like two
scenes where it was very obvious that it
would change nothing about the other
person's decision but it's obvious that
maya is definitely not i mean she's echo
she's gonna have her own show she's not
gonna be a bad guy if anything what i
like and what they've done with her i i
imagine i kind of liking it a little bit
more towards punisher and daredevil
season two
where you present this character in an
antagonistic position who eventually by
the end of the series is actually a
protagonist and i think in episode six
she's gonna break good like we're gonna
see her go to that side to launch into
her show i agree and they've set her up
so well that she's fascinating and
captivating where you're gonna want to
follow her good deeds true absolutely
but my one another scene that i really
loved was the
it was almost meditative part of me
wished like wish i didn't have complete
hearing in my ear
when he's talking to peace man
when he talks to natasha or he's like or
you know spiritually talking to natasha
takes out the earpiece and then all the
noise around him fades away so he can
feel like he's having a direct
conversation with her yeah it's
beautiful the whole performance of what
he's been doing
just clicked for me fully like i've
already really been enjoying the hell
out of what jeremy renner's been doing
um but then as a whole new layer got
added on in that one scene
where he's talking about uh i forget
exactly what he said but it was
something about how
you know the the gift you gave me the
gift of life basically is like i'm
trying to have a life i'm trying to take
this opportunity be with my family
enjoy it but i'm having a hard time
because man do i feel a lot of pain over
my past and man do i miss the hell out
of you too and i replay that moment all
the time of
losing you and how it should have been
me and i'm trying to appreciate what you
gave me but i can't so all of that
subtly just made every
moment we've seen of him in this show
like this all clicks
it all even makes more sense and then he
has the end game i've seen a lot right
now
yeah that scene like obviously there's
dialogue about her wanting to have him
with his family but now it's his
reaction to that these two years later
for us in real time getting to see how
that's impacted him in these these years
since and that's so beautiful
i love these long-form shows like it's
giving us so much so many scenes we
couldn't get it's just like when you
read weekly comic books when you read
floppies you get so many impactful
moments as compared to like picking up
just the trades of series like the like
if you pick up an event comic there's
gonna be spin-off books that most people
don't read but in those spin-off books
you get these moments and i feel like
marvel has done an incredible job making
these spin-off shows feel like weekly
comic books without feeling like
spin-offs from the movies especially
hawkeye i feel like kevin feige's really
established a tone that's going to
parallel monthly comics not monthly
spin-off comics this feels just as
essential as the movies but it doesn't
feel like you're beholden to one or the
other you get just enhanced both with
the shows yeah very true i love the way
you think coy
kevin guy knows comics coy
so
jack du kane
swordsman bait and switch i think that
whole thing was a ruse
that he's actually a bad guy together i
think he's actually a bad guy and they
put that whole thing together
for kate's eyes to witness
i like that
i think it's just a concept back and
forth
of one of the not as interesting
elements of the show
i was like all right
everything else
can we bring back the toffee like i want
the answers
i think it's interesting i don't want to
say it's not interesting i'm saying on
the list
on the list of interesting it's not one
of the most interesting yeah
it would not change much it wouldn't
change my emotional association to the
show basically um but i'm sure actually
i imagine it would hold a heavier weight
by the time we get the full impact of
the of the information
by that point i do think it's gonna land
it's just while it's like simmering it
hasn't felt like a thing but when it
lands i feel like it's gonna make the
show better kind of like what we just
had at the hawkeye moment it's gonna
make everything like the dominoes fall
in a fun way because especially jack
duquesne was exceptionally
more confident like confident in the
fact of like
i was framed this wasn't me i'll be in
time for your christmas tent like it was
just so
he he didn't seem at all like if he was
actually framed like like truly framed
to the point where
this was all just completely oblivious
to him i imagine he would be a lot more
dismayed
that would be some it's this type of
concern but there is
not like not no concern at all so it
made me think like oh
they're doing the like the prediction
that
eleanor set him up but
i think they're both in on it in some
way that's my theory we only have one
episode left solid theory
they got to introduce the multiverse
immediately
that's what every ten that's what every
marvel thing is about
when are the x-men
i hope so that would be amazing so we
gotta have kingpin in the next episode
we've got to solve the mystery of the
murder we need to have the yelena a bit
paid off we need to have the maya bit
paid off we need to have kate bishop
rejoin with hawkeye lucky be named we
need to have lucky be named we need to
hopefully have grills be like uh handing
the suits over and then fully suit up we
need to have quasi be a little bit more
accurate to his comic and not be such a
[ __ ] i would like that a little ah
because man
if you guys read the comic this ain't
ruining [ __ ] for you because it ain't
definitely happening in this show
it's so
lethal and menacing in the toughest foe
who
for clint he like whoops ass he's the
big bad he's the [ __ ] he's the big bad
yeah and
although it's making me wonder now
think it's a big switch too i don't know
i think it's a baiting switch i'm
wondering if if they do keep this this
series that like like hey hawkeye season
two if they're setting him up to be a
bigger villain oh
and the next one
i just want turk
if kingpins canon turks can and turk
kept it all together on netflix i want
turk back i want clint's brother oh
that'd be fun i'd like the name's not
barry what is it it's barney barney
barney yeah yeah
barney that's what the coin thinking
because barney barton is the first
well guys another great episode of
hawkeye um sure to
get people talking with an official
confirmation
that kevin feige does not entirely
hating netflix
he's seen him he's lost he's
like
that's the same i'm having an impression
we're only getting daredevil stuff i
don't think yeah with justin jones
not iron fist
yeah but if like if this version of
kingpin's around you know that that's
that's very telling so i would love to
already marry jessica jones and luke
cage like already established like
they've they've already like
catching up as it's moved along cause we
called like if you know jessica jones
baby got blipped luke caged it and they
got a kid and stuff running around
yeah
their stories itself
well
[Laughter]
guys what do you think about this
episode are you excited that the the
king of pins is back
subscribe click that notification bell
tell us in the comments your favorite
thing about vincent d'onofrio that is
not kingpin
skin suit men in black sugar and water
did a war movie did pretty well
magnificent several magnificent seven
yep very tall metal jacket
no i wasn't going to say the correct
answer
but then again i what do we know we only
know marvel
okay hey we should do
maria hammond maria
has sent us so many gifts this year and
she sent us a message on social media i
say she sent us so many gifts she sent
us so many gifts maria thank you yeah
she's a sweetheart
really looks after her son who is a
great recovery process right now i won't
go into too much specifics but you are
one hell of a caring mother and you even
look after us like we're your own
children and i love the hell out of you
for it on top of that too she messaged
me saying we're gonna be getting more
[ __ ] for christmas
it's actually in the mailbox oh it's in
the mail it's in the mailbox
we're so busy we can't drive over there
[Laughter]
but it is there it takes a lot it takes
longer than you think but maria
my dear if you had a bow and arrow
right to our hearts but it would it
wouldn't be lethal no it would be an
arrow made of love like you right to our
hearts shout out to the heart but you're
too late you know what i do you love a
bad name i would accept it's that's
bonjour mean spontaneous
the best name yeah
love his name
love thy name
it's two in the morning
he's playing insulted
[Laughter]
and uh you're part of the reject family
we accept you in here a little bit more
than others
she just loves a good madam mask of the
real region in a good way a good man
me and john about it this we're doing
villainous things
if you ever come out to cali let us know
we'll take you out to dinner
or
a little light snack
proper dinner
thank you
[Music]